bien bonjour à tous j'espère que vous
allez bien tout se passe bien pour vous
d'ailleurs dit que les mois dès
maintenant bas en commentaire vous
voulez acheter un nouvel iphone en 2021
mais vous ne savez pas nécessairement
lequel choisir faut dire que ça devient
compliqué il ya beaucoup de produits je
crois que l'année dernière c'est la
première année où apple a sorti autant
d'iphone en une seule et même année à 12
il faut ne pouvait ni iphone 12 pro
iphone 12 trop max et dans la première
partie de l'année
l iphone et ce nouvelle version de
l'iphone n'est ce pas moins de 5 iphone
en une année on avait l'habitude il ya
quelques années en arrière d'avoir deux
iphone par exemple l'iphone 6 6 +77 +88
plus on a eu ensuite avec l'iphone 10s
l'iphone 10s 10s max et l'iphone 10 r 3
iphone c'est déjà beaucoup pour apple et
l'année dernière pas moins de 5 iphone
alors en 2021
on ne devrait pas avoir 5 iphone arrêté
puisque l'iphone et ce ne sera pas
reconduit on aurait donc normalement
potentiellement quatre nouveaux iphone
et fun 13 iphone 13 mini iphone 13 pro
iphone 13 promax ça on garde en
hypothétique et on verra ça dans la
deuxième partie de l'année d'ailleurs
vous invite dès maintenant à venir vous
abonner pour tout savoir de la critique
que ce soit des iphone on part également
de smartphones sous android n'ont pas
bien évidemment de montrer qu tu es de
tablettes et de toute votre vie
numérique donc ça c'est génial on va
donc aujourd'hui regarder qu'à l'iphone
est fait pour vous en 2021 qu'à l'iphone
acheté il ya une grosse nébuleuse pascal
beaucoup d'iphone on va devenir
dégrossir tous à regarder les
différentes gammes regarder les prix
c'est de comprendre quelles sont les
différences entre les différents modèles
pour savoir quel iphone est fait pour
vous en 2021
[Musique]
il ya quelques prérequis avant de
commander cette vidéo on va donc définir
déjà ce qu'on peut trouver sur le site
d'apple je peux trouver ailleurs dans le
commerce et ensuite faire la distinction
entre le 9 et le reconditionner sur le
site d'apple on ne retrouve pas tous les
iphone au catalogue cette année il vous
reste toute la gamme iphone 12 ce qui
est normal iphone 12 12 min 12 pro douce
promax c'est normal on également les
phonons qu'il conservait assez
intéressant et l'iphone 10r l'iphone 10r
faut savoir qu'il ya quand même deux ans
mais il est conservé on a bien
évidemment l'iphone est ce de 2020 et
c'est tout pas plus pas moins l'iphone
rostro ans prendra x ne sont plus du
tout aux catalogues 10 16 17 max non
plus et l'iphone 10 supprimés et tous
les iphones antérieurs ne sont plus du
tout présent en tout cas dans la vente
en neuf ça c'est chez apple mais chez
d'autres revendeurs que sont au final
darty boulanger cdiscount rueducommerce
et compagnie et je vous en passe et des
meilleurs et bien vous allez pouvoir
retrouver d'autres iphone et iphone plus
anciens et bien souvent sur la
marketplace est ce que pour autant ces
iphone anciens sont intéressants par
rapport à leur prix on va s'emparer dans
quelques instants les plus ensuite vous
avez les sites qu'on appelle de
reconditionner qui sont des smartphones
qui ont déjà eu une première vie ils
sont récupérés par les entreprises ils
en font un tour complet ils vérifient
tous les points et les remettent en état
si besoin et vous vous achetez un
produit d'occasion avec une garantie
fait par un professionnel donc ça c'est
extrêmement rassurant
maintenant il ya un point extrêmement
important à connaître chez apple c'est
ce qu'on appelle la valeur résiduelle la
valeur résiduelle
c'est la valeur que garde votre iphone
dans les mois et dans les années qui
suivent votre achat et chez apple on a
une valeur résiduelle qui est
extrêmement forte ça veut dire qu'un
iphone qu'on a acheté l'année dernière
un iphone 11
elles font aux pros on se prend acte peu
importe ils ne décollent pas beaucoup il
garde un prix assez élevé
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
n'avez pas voir les tarifs s'effondrer
quelques mois à prévoir un an un an et
demi voire deux ans après vous en tirez
moins cher si vous le vendez votre
opérateur ou si vous le revendez pas
tant qui fait du reconditionnés mais si
vous vendez directement particulier à
particulier
eh bien vous en tirez un prêt qui sera
tout de suite beaucoup plus élevés donc
cette notion de valeur résiduelle elle
est extrêmement importante soit
prérequis extrêmement important n'était
pas d'iphone avec une capacité de
stockage inférieur à 64 giga je vous
déconseille fortement 16 giga de
stockage la proscrire 32 gigas et pas
assez 64 giga minimum puisque les
données aux
dans le temps puisque les applications
deviennent de plus en plus gourmande 64
giga minimum et une fois de plus je vous
renvoie avec un lien en bas dans la
description et puis il ya un autre point
qui est extrêmement important c'est
d'anticiper le vieillissement de son
iphone
aujourd'hui je fais cette vidéo nous
sommes en 2021 d'où le titre de la vidéo
quel iphone acheté en 2021 vous avez
compris ça très logique donc votre
nouvel iphone ou d algarve des trois ans
pour garder deux ans ne changez pas en
dessous de 2 ans ça ne sert à rien trois
ans c'est vraiment une durée de vie
totalement normal pour un iphone vous
allez garder votre iphone 3 ans nous
emmène donc de 2021 à 2024 je suis bon
vous avez vu ce qui veut donc dire que
si vous achetez un iphone qui est trop
ancien et bien il se peut que dans un an
ou dans deux ans vous gagneriez pour les
mises à jour d'ios vos galères gay pour
les mises à jour de vos applications
donc des fois ça va vous coûter un poil
plus cher passer à la génération
suivante
mais ça vous évitera de désagréments
dans un an deux ans ou la arrivera un
moment où il se peut que ça coince on va
donc se concentrer tout de suite pour
savoir qu'à l'iphone vous vous devez
acheter en 2021
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec rhinochill
parce qu'avoir un beau smartphone
l'iphone c'est bien mais il faut venir
ici le protéger et shine chine vous avez
de quoi faire vous avez différentes
collections notamment regardez-moi ça
comme c'est super sympa la nba avec les
chicago bulls
vous avez aussi des coques approuvé par
la nasa donc si vous êtes fan de
l'espace regardez bien franchement vous
dit quoi faire ça ce sont des solides
suite aux récents les suit ce sont les
coques de rhinau chine comme peut
tourner tous les côtés ça paye
survêtement ça fait du bruit mais
surtout c'est résistance afghane
protégez vous avez également des coques
fortnight vous avez du hunter vous en
avez pour tous vos smartphones que ce
soit de l'iphone 12 min que ce soit fort
de l'iphone 12 promax il y en a pour
tout le monde et en plus vous avez
différents types de modèles vous avez de
la crh garde enix avec une petite glace
de protection l'arrière prévient opus
customiser des différentes couleurs et
vous voulez ensuite les customiser avec
différents modèles dans différentes
ambiances league of legends sera ya
plein de trucs super sympa vous avez
également les crashs gars vous avez les
modes et nick
différentes couleurs différents formats
pour différentes d'un poignet puis
surtout vous avez des protections
d'écran parce que oui il faut aussi
protéger votre écran vous en avez
différentes sortes et ça c'est vachement
bien merci qui merci rhinochill merci
rideau chic de sponsoriser cette vidéo
je vous ai mis les liens en bas dans la
description en venant de la part vous
avez une remise spéciale tout est
indiqué en bas dans la description aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil pour vous
faire plaisir pour ce soit c'est clair
et lisible on va regarder les
différentes gammes vous avez la gamme de
l'année dernière vous avez l'iphone 12
d'iphone 12 pro 12 pro mac 12 min et le
est ce ici vous allez iphone qui vont
vous coûter les plus chers qui seront
également les iphone les plus récentes
on va ensuite regarder une autre gamme
qui est assez intéressante c'est ce
qu'on avait l'année d'avant c'est à dire
la gamme de 2019 avec 11 11 pro et le
onze probable ce qui reste pour moi
aussi des smartphones qui sont vraiment
très très très actuel et qui marche
vraiment très très bien alors après on
avait d'autres modèles mais qui commence
vraiment à vieillir je vous recommande
pas laisser ce avant d'aller serrer
gagne de 2018 avec le dissès le dissès
max et le 10 r c'est intéressant parce
que le dise terre est encore au
catalogue
c'est pas nécessairement un produit sur
lequel je vous conseillerais d'aller
c'est plus un produit pour avoir un prix
un peu plus bas c'est vraiment une
notion de prix en fait un si vous voulez
aujourd'hui chez apple je pense qu'ils
sont en train de se repositionner en
termes de politique tarifaire ils ne
vont pas baisser leurs prix donc ils
vous proposent des modèles plus anciens
plus bas c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous retrouvez encore les faunes 10r au
catalogue qui à mon avis aujourd'hui n'a
plus trop raison d'être sur le site
d'apple en tout cas et puis sur les
modèles de 2017 vous avez les fundis
effet une nuitée 8 pouces un joli tout
de suite les modèles de 2017 on les
prend on les jette on les oublie
l'iphone vista smartphones qui est trop
vieux qui même si pour l'instant il ya
trois ans parce qu'ils étaient présentés
fin 2017
il est beaucoup trop vieux et vous
risquez dans deux ans pour trouver un
écho smartphone obsolète des guillemets
quand j'ai ça mais je le pense vous
allez avoir la puce à 11 bionique
commence vraiment à me dire et même la
gamme de 2018 voyez je suis pas
nécessairement fans c'est une question
de budget c'est toujours une question de
budget on peut y aller mais une fois de
plus pensez vraiment vieillissement des
produits surtout qu'ici on garde une
valeur résiduelle qui est fort il faut
il vaut mieux trouver un iphone on se
prononce promax en reconditionnés qui
vous coûtera moins cher plutôt qu'à
acheter un iphone 10r sur le site
d'apple qui nous coûtera un peu plus
cher
déjà la première chose c'est de venir
séparer les gammes on a plein de modèles
que nous a montrée apple en 2020 avec
ces quatre modèles c'est cette
segmentation de gamme un iphone pour
tout le monde vous avez le plus petit
iphone c'est l'iphone 12 min l'iphone
2000 il est vraiment intéressant pour
toutes les personnes qui veulent des
petits smartphones quelque chose d'autre
léger très compact qu'on peut utiliser
très facilement humains qui veulent un
smartphone qu'on peut ranger dans un
petit sac à main très discret on ne va
pas s'encombrer on veut être chez apple
on veut l'écosystème on veut eyeos mais
on ne veut pas s'embêter vous avez un
très bel écran oled vous aurez un très
bon appareil photo vous aimerez soir
tranquille raymonde extrêmement bonne
qualité mais en format mini en format
compact vous avez un écran oled de 5 2 4
pouces full hd plus vous avez la
dernière puce et la a14 bionique qui
marche très bien vous avez deux
objectifs à l'arrière un grand angle
ultra grand angle qui feront très très
bien le boulot qui marchent
merveilleusement bien vous avez la 5g
n'accepte les dernières techno de si
vous voulez un petit iphone petits pas
le format iphone 2010 clairement ça ne
l'a vu le 4 pouces alors c'est
intéressant parce que les autres années
vous aviez un iphone 11 avec un écran
5,8 pouces ce format là a disparu tac
fini basta l'iphone 12 se retrouve
maintenant avec un écran de 6,1 pouces
et est le format de l'iphone onze pros
donc si vous avez un iphone 12 avec un
écran un peu plus grand ont pas cette
fois ci sur duo led full hd + alors
qu'avant on avait un écran lcd en hd on
va donc monter en qualité
ici on s'adresse aux personnes qui
veulent l'iphone de base jeudi de base
de battre on est dans le premium cadeaux
la base elle est extrêmement premium
vous avez ce qui se fait mais une fois
de plus vous avez la puce à 14 bionique
vous avez deux capteurs à l'arrière
grand angle ultra grand-angle qui
marchent merveilleusement bien vous avez
la 5g vous avez le mcs safe et ensuite
on va bien monté dans le professionnel
ou là on va venir ajouté le téléobjectif
pour les personnes qui ont vraiment
l'usagé du zoom avec l'iphone 12 pro
vous garder le même format que l'iphone
12 écran 10,1 pouces oled full hd plus
on a sensiblement la même chose sauf que
cette fois ci la différence à seurre au
niveau de la photo vous avez trois
objectif grand angle ultra grand-angle
et vous rajoutez le thé l'objectif plus
la caméra lidar qui est le laser qui
vous servira notamment pour le mode
portrait qui me servira aussi pour la
photo nuit puisqu'il doit venir mesurer
directement la distance en sera très
très bien ça servira également pour tous
qui va être réalité augmentée notamment
mesure d'objets et compagnie bon là on
est déjà dans le dans le haut de gamme
ça commence à coûter cher et si vous
voulez aller beaucoup plus loin l'iphone
que j'ai c'est l'iphone 12 pronax on
aura tel objectif de encore meilleure
qualité on ira plus loin au niveau de la
stabilisation sans votre capteur
principal
et puis surtout on aura un écran
gigantesque de 6,7 pouces là où sont
l'iphone on se prend max on avait un
écran déjà gigantesque de 6,5 pouces et
puis vous avez
seul l'iphone est ce c'est le design old
school d'apple mais avec les
performances des iphone de 2019 avec la
puce à 13 bionique avec un seul capteur
mais qui marchent merveilleusement bien
cette capture principal que vous avez
sur l'iphone onze pros il est top marche
très bien vous avez un smartphone qui
est vraiment bien il sera beaucoup moins
cher mais par contre il faut aimer les a
gâtés push school et puis si vous avez
un écran de 4,7 pouces
c'est assez petit par contre c'est un
smartphone qui est 4g ici pas de 5 g à
savoir si pour vous la singette
important toutes parts ici non plus pas
de faisal dit on à 4 shaggy mais ça
fonctionne puis surtout on est à moins
de 500 euros sur un iphone 9 et ça s'est
vraiment bien donc voyez déjà rien que
sur 2020 on a eu toute cette gamme qui
est énorme
du plus petit au plus grand avec des
écrans oled de partout sauf sur l'iphone
et ce avec d'excellents capteur photo de
tous les côtés y beaucoup de
performances quelles que soient les
smartphones du et ce jusqu'au 12 pronax
devait beaucoup de performances mais par
contre les prix sont là l'iphone douce
et 909 euros dans la plus petite
configuration le 12 pro 1159 euros le 12
promax 1259 les fautes 12 min on à 809
tandis que l'iphone est ce je vous le
dis on a moins de 500 euros et 1 489
euros dont la question qui se pose ici
c'est savoir quel est le dernier iphone
que vous voulez et là vous avez les
moyens vous avez le budget pour venir
choisir un iphone très récent bon je
parle de budget de la qualification
c'est déjà beaucoup mieux maintenant se
pose la question de l'iphone 11
puisqu'on garde toujours l'iphone 11 au
catalogue d'apple toute la gamme de 2019
se trouve très bien très actuel pour moi
si vous le trouvez un bon prix vous
pouvez y aller que ce soit l'iphone 11
l'iphone onze pros ou l'iphone 11 promax
iphone os promax que j'ai gardé pendant
quasiment le mans qui a un excellent
smartphone ce qui donne vraiment envie à
guider votre choix entre les modèles de
2019 et les modèles de 2020 c'est le
prix le prix le prix est uniquement le
prix donc pour moi si vous trouvez les
iphone 11
on se prend au jeu promax en
reconditionnés beaucoup moins cher
allez-y quand je dis beaucoup moins cher
c'est entre 150 euros à 200 euros
d'écart par rapport au prix les épaules
de la génération suivante les compris
l'histoire est l'iphone distance reste
intéressant aujourd'hui ma réponse est
non
sauf sauf si le prix est très bas et là
vous êtes encore en dessous des 200
euros si vous ne trouvez l'iphone 10s
l'iphone 10 as max ou l'iphone 10r à des
prix vraiment extrêmement intéressant
sur dur conditionnelle je vous dirai
pourquoi pas mais n'allez pas sur iphone
de génial
son précédentes parce que vraiment ça va
pas le faire parce qu'ils vont commencer
à vieillir et de fait plus il faut se
projeter dans le temps dans les années à
venir quant aux anciennes gammes 8 7 6
16 6 5 à 5,5 et compagnie tout ça vous
oubliez vous oubliez alors vous les
trouverez pas très cher certains à moins
de 100 euros
mais d'une voudrais pas dans les os 2 2
vous n'aurez pas de lanières
applications et puis de 3 dans les
années à venir voilà ça servira
strictement rien la qualité photo n'est
pas la fin ça ne sert à rien si vraiment
terme de bouger ça passe pas je vous
conseille d'aller sur un smartphone
android ou à des prix beaucoup plus bas
vous trouverez des smartphones qui
marche très bien pourquoi pas de l'année
précédente sans qu'elle vous serez pas
déçu mais ça c'est une autre histoire on
en parlera dans une prochaine vidéo
posez-vous donc cette question d'une
quel est mon budget est ce que votre
budget est très élevé auquel cas on peut
être les iphone de 2020 qui sont top
tous
et puis le deuxième point c'est qu'elle
est le smartphone dans la gamme qui vous
convient petit smartphone grand
smartphone quels sont vos besoins en
termes de photos est ce que vous avez
besoin d'un tel objectif si vous n'avez
pas besoin d'un téléobjectif
n'allez pas sur un iphone 12 pro aller
sur l'iphone 12 allée sur un iphone
11 regardez bien évidemment la taille de
votre écran puisque le multimédia est un
des usages primordial des usages les
plus importants ayant un point
extrêmement important à savoir c'est que
bien qu'on ait un écran hd lcd sur
l'iphone 11 vous avez quand même un très
bel écran extrêmement bien calibré c'est
la même chose sur l'iphone et ce très
beau écran très bien calibrée très bien
maîtrisé donc ne bloquait pas sur la
fiche technique là dessus quoi qu'il en
soit vous aurez des iphone qui font de
très bonnes photos qui seront
performants je vous conseille une fois
de plus d'être dans la gamme des iphone
12 des iphones 11 iphone 10 aces mais
pas en dessous vraiment aujourd'hui en
n'allez pas en dessous donc pour
récapituler si j'ai un petit budget
iphone et se marche très très bien
on peut rater aussi du côté de l'iphone
10r sinon regarder pour les anciens
modèles jusqu'à l'iphone dit c'est sont
reconditionnés vous pas trop des choses
intéressantes à voir en confiance à plus
de votre budget si vous voulez un iphone
un peu standard standard avec des
guillemets qui marche très bien
iphone 11 iphone 12 si vous voulez un
petit format très actuelle est très
performant iphone 12 min l'iphone 11 pro
l'iphone 12 pro seront vraiment très bon
très performant vous irez très loin en
photo vous avez surtout avoir un
téléobjectif et ça s'est vraiment bien
donc si vous allez vraiment faire de la
photo en toute circonstance l'iphone 11
pro iphone 12 pro marche seront vraiment
bien et même pour multimédia vous avez
des grands écrans serra très bien
mais si vous voulez en suisse qui se
fait de mieux en terme de performance ou
des très grands écrans iphone on se
prend max iphone 12 promax tout en
sachant qu'avec le 12 promax vous aurez
tout de suite ce qui est mieux ce cas
très très haut aujourd'hui chez apple et
dernière question très importante à vous
poser dès maintenant
c'est la question de la 5g la 5g est
arrivé là 5 g arrive la 5g se développe
se déploie donc si vous mettez de
l'argent et vous pensé passer sur un
abonnement 5 j allais sur les iphone 12
avec les quatre modèles vous aurez de la
5g bon dès lors vous avez pris un
abonnement simple vous ai compris un peu
l'histoire puisque vous allez les gars
des de 2 à 3 ans et il se peut que
l'année prochaine ou en cours de cette
année vous souhaitez prendre
l'abonnement 5g autant avoir un
smartphone qui puisse être compatible 5g
dès maintenant autant vous dire que
d'iphone 12e le son est uniquement les
iphone 12
par exemple lorsque j'avais à vous
donner pour vous aider pour vous guider
dans votre achat de votre iphone en 2021
dites moi ce que vous en pensez
surtout n'hésitez pas si vous avez des
questions en bas en commentaire il
gardait toujours cette logique d'une le
format de deux le prix et pour trouver
votre iphone au meilleur prix une fois
de plus je vous aime tous les liens en
bas dans la description sur se donnent
rendez vous extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler tech pour vous guider
dans vos achats des achats malins pour
trouver tous les produits au meilleur
prix sur ce nous embrassons va beaucoup
d'amour des coeurs et à très vite car